our next presenter to give the award for
the director of the year there's not
only one of the great all-time stars of
the screen but also the best looking
tycoon you'll ever see
father Oscar winner miss Joan proper
Joe after the ceremonies tonight I hope
you'd be able to drop by the house well
I'll certainly try Bob oh good I've got
a garage full of empty
those nominators for the best
achievement in director are Peter
Glanville for Beckett Stanley Kubrick
for dr. Strangelove or how I learned to
stop worrying and love the bomb Robert
Stevenson for Mary Poppins George Cukor
from my fair lady Michael Carcano or
Zorba the Greek and the winner is mr.
George keeper
I'm very grateful very happy and very
lucky I had wonderful material to work
with
I then named all these people that
helped I want to thank mr. Jack Horner
who gave every support every
encouragement wonderful August to work
with I must make a deep file to mr. Rick
Harrison and two adorable Audrey Hepburn
I thank everybody thank you
I I have a telegram I think you'd like
to hear which to the members of the
Academy as I'm sorry that I'm not able
to be with you tonight I send my love to
you all Patricia Neal
this year well now we come to the moment
of truth the best picture of the year
right now there are five anxious
producers seated in our audience biting
fingernails not their their assistants
to present the best picture award is the
man who two years ago kept a Mockingbird
and came up with an Oscar
mr. Gregory Peck
denominations for the best picture of
the year are dr. Strangelove or how I
learned to stop worrying and love the
bomb Hawk films Columbia Stanley kicker
second Hal Wallis production paramount
Hal B Wallis my fair lady Warner
Brothers Jack L Warner Zorba the Greek
grossly production international
classics Michael Tatiana and Mary
Poppins Walt Disney Productions Walt
Disney and Bill walk
the envelope the best picture of the
year is my fair lady back and runner
I am deed gratified to be here tonight
to accept this high award and I want to
thank first the Academy and its members
for making it possible
secondly and equally I would say I want
to thank mr. George Bernard Shaw for
writing Pygmalion passing it into the
hands of Allen Lerner
then to the great composer Frederick
Loewe then into George Cukor the
director is able to sub societal
assistance
Cecil Beaton Jean Allen George Hopkins I
can name them for on and on but time is
of the essence I don't want to cut off
the I don't think but I want to thank
you very very much ladies and gentlemen
for presenting this for my fair lady
it's something we will always be proud
of and I speak for those in the back
lock the front lock upstairs Downstairs
everywhere I know they thank yous and I
thank you for them